back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
ah read the dark web man ah dude it
definitely is man armor one night he
brought a escort to the comedy store and
she got in a fight on the front porch
and got taken off dude you can't have
escorts as your plus-one
yeah bro that's where s course you get
dangerous bro when you gets plus 100 I'm
gonna take home to this wedding yeah
this wedding and they bring butterfly I
always have butterflies and high heels
one of them had a sigh one time like
that Ninja Turtle you know the one that
carries that weird weapon oh yeah I'm
talking about Michelangelo yeah dude yes
you pull she's like oh do you have any
of these but you pulled out a side I was
like sure she didn't pull out of her tip
dude where she pulled it out of but you
can't an escort you can only I mean I
guess that's not you I guess you could
to take an escort on a vacation sounds
hey you know how you know when your
friends take escorts on vacations
cuz if you go the escorts page it's
always just them on a giant yacht with
our ass out
where's just them selfies like yeah no
guy anywhere is nobody around
hey is it re in Hawaii they did already
posters on a bow yeah that boat looks
very similar to hit it goes I'd like to
see some like chicks that are like on a
catfish boat or something like that ya
know - like real ratchet yeah I wanna
bet some escorts if you try to take them
on something real regular they would be
like nah I gonna Dave and Buster's going
to bowling and drinking Bud Light but
your friend come on dude you do it for
the gram dude we need some real escorts
I'm talking about some down escort
they're not gonna be fine then we just
your basic what girl with that box body
like I'll do it yeah bucks yeah - her
bucks in an uber
that kind of girl is got four shoulders
you mean dude I can't man singing with
them Kansas City [ __ ] head you can
stack a couple on each other in a corner
bro came to stand in line at your
favorite barbeque place dude Derrick
would you say really you had lunch at
the restaurant that is lunch with the
purse Hey
yeah I went to a football game with
Roger Goodell I will say okay now we're
talking about and what what really
happened to it we went to me and my girl
went to lunch at our spot where was this
at Tony or cafe met it's raining really
good where's that North Hollywood okay
so good we go in there it's our spots
our regular spot there's a big black SUV
outside like the kind rich people have
yeah and we walk in Brody's Halle Berry
and like a group of agents really just
hurting the whole place and she's
yelling about John Jones and then I was
like right and she was like this guy you
know have lunch with her she kept
talking to me we kept making eye contact
her nine agents this is us it sounds
kind of sort of this is us
dude I was in a restaurant that's broken
then yeah now were you how many what
were the people that were like her with
what kind of people were okay a lot of
white boys I know what so you and her
had like an urban did you feel an urban
kind of something same skin call you
guys do this gonna be your little
brother dude that's what I felt like
yeah we're old barely yeah I wanna see
you in that movie I'm billion dollar
whatever it is when that lady gets do
that no I stopped watching right after
she uh right after she like is in
fight in the middle the end is too much
it is so sad Oh see that tracheotomy too
well if you give me of a senior that
when you have Clint Eastwood is a severe
senior citizen at this point
did you see the mule uh-uh dude give me
my [ __ ] money back Clint Eastwood
first of all he's 97 years old he wrote
dealt in it he's holding off wrote
directed and starred in it it's just him
driving on a long highway and cruise
control and apparently smuggling drugs
and then he has a scene where he finally
gets to wherever the cartel and he has a
threesome with two hot Mexican like of
course it's old dirtbag wrote this dude
he probably stopped at a pharmacy I'm
surprised due to any senior citizen
Lerner long drive he's going to a
pharmacy we're honored dude a lot of
time when you're a senior citizen that's
like the only store that still exists I
think is a pharmacy you know if you
tickle a senior citizen they just yell
out pharmacy love them you'll use weak
speaking of mewling hiding some of your
body you got a freakin baby bro
congratulations dude
large and Cha is he really Austin J yeah
he's here bro Boston can we bring up
some regular looking mint just random
men from Boston can you type that in I'm
from Boston well
Austin's an English term but let's see
how many people are gonna be able to
relate to him constantly just random men
from Boston
look at that dimepiece far-left that's
Captain America is it really yeah let's
go a different town let's go right
outside of Boston can you pick Southie a
South Boston guy go to Whitey Bulger
that's what my son looks like does he
really he looks like Whitey Bulger how
big is he he's a big kid 99% tile I'm I
create big kids when he came out his
eyes cuz their eyes are weird too like
almost like glassy like all like almost
like a shark like your baby shark it's
just all black I'm like it looks like
he's been through three tours of Vietnam
he's just like he has PTSD I went what's
wrong with them that's like nothing they
can't they can't really see I'm like he
seen some [ __ ] like [ __ ] tell him that
kids with you
man oven what he did but it comes out
he's just like he's cute though
maybe he came from like a different
spirit maybe oh here's some people right
there some Antipa fights oh yeah there's
a girl in green it's st. Patty's Day
everyday in some of these small town no
he looks like bloody Boulder that's what
he looks like a lot of women with
bandanas yeah yeah there is looks like
yeah on the far right you looks like an
old man does he yeah he does why do you
bowl just been through some [ __ ] can he
communicate yet or what is it like does
you have oh just just eating a lot dude
and sleeping that's all they do it's all
kids yeah
you don't seem effective I mean you seem
excited but I'm excited I love it yeah
out of pressure is it a lot of pressure
I love the what does he seem demanding
or something yes me demands or he wants
a car you know do give us alcohol
problem that's for a gold chain tell
Chris D'Elia to chip him off a few grams
rock crystal is wearing that junkyard
dog necklace that little Aussie necklace
little bo-peep or whatever that guy's
name was it died dude how was uh
Thanksgiving New Orleans oh it was good
man people selling right I mean the good
thing is like if you start on the map
and you start up it like Michigan or
whatever to meat and potatoes and the
further down the map you go people eat
to the gift is just whatever you know
people just spitting in their mouths and
just you know somebody else oh so yeah
we had everything man had a bunch of
Gator bites some dude really yeah
they'll sell you see these people with
these you know like uh canned sodas
they'll come for six packs in that
cardboard thing yeah
and then you'll see a guy sell that but
it's just Gator bites in there and it's
just like oh the first seven or eight
are tasty it's kind of like you know
Chinese food like if you have it fast
it's good yeah and the further like in
the beginning its sirloin
by 40 minutes later it is [ __ ] a time
with orange chicken I got a Panda
Express
it's Labrador about yeah yeah I'm like
what am i eating this dog covered in
orange syrup yeah I think it is cuz I
get the double scoop with rice oh just
get the single scoop bro oh you go
double scoop yeah yeah that second scoop
is so dangerous I feel like you guys
know about that cat the older that
Chinese food gets or the more over time
it's almost like that game show where
it's like a timer or that man with Mel
Gibson or something where are you
talking about Passion of Christ no oh
lift oh no way further in time than that
oh you're talking about lethal weapon
lethal weapon yes yes yeah pop quiz hot
hot boy that's Pedro whatever quiz pop
boy where they tell the guy in the pop
quiz [ __ ] all these booty boys down
there hi quiz booty boy too many booty
boys do these days a lot of men just
traveling through the world but first
bro and that dude that's a new man's how
men are doing it now did you see that
gif of what's name Raja
have you seen that when he's looking at
that he's like the best player in the
NBA right now that European kid and Raj
is on the bench and you know kids like
stand up waiting for the ball Raj just
look at him like he's a full rack of
ribs like Raja definitely like the way
the dick takes its rage on is it raise
young was it come Raja
like the high drop get your life
together
no wait to see the video hey that boy
wants a piece does he owe his mouth is
salivating where do you see this I think
if you scroll down yeah right here this
leave this I've never looked at another
man like this in my life
that I know of well that's on film
what's this what what dude raishin there
you chambers don't lie bro change that
hard to a G bruh dude that's on same
thing everybody's a booty boy now people
men walking booty first through the
world bro you got to go wiener first
dude and take on the world were we
talking about earlier there's something
oh thanks giving that was okay tor bytes
dude so these men yeah they have these
little trays of Gator bites and at first
they're hot and they're like you know
good it's like an you know just like a
McNugget yeah but you have [ __ ] 9 of
them that 10th one it's like you're like
damn these [ __ ] got strong you know
yeah I get halfway through anything like
what am i doing yeah they start biting
back it just gets dangerous dude they
start tasting like people used to know
kind of they [ __ ] taste shady that's
what you had for Thanksgiving though yes
I had some Gator bites what else did we
have Oh Cajun hot sauce what do we have
on him some type of gravy
probably just regular gravy mashed
potatoes a lot of dirty rice down there
I like me some dirt rice dude yes we had
some venison a lot of deer meat okay
when a little gamey for the things
yeah gets a little gamey dude no owl my
sister use owl actually a couple years
ago we had al over there what else did
they have dude holy any pies yeah we had
just a basic type of dessert what was it
oh yeah it was actually was a bread
pudding pie who cook this um my
brother's wife's family hell yeah and
dude their house has been flooded a
couple times you know they have good
food dude if you live in a lake bro you
know that [ __ ] dude you're gonna have
something good yeah it floods in Vietnam
every year doesn't it cut every single
year typhoon season every year Mekong
right yeah for some places Viacom
Vietcong I don't think no is it the VC
dude yeah okay sorry about Joe Biden
that's how you're talking about
right and what is that so every year it
floods and they rebuild their houses
right yeah or sometimes you just kind of
relocate naturally your house just kind
of like floats away if do I do the up
thing put my [ __ ] on some balloons just
dip out every year that's what they do
they just get they kind of do they
really shouldn't flow have homes that
they use like hands to keep afloat and
whenever it floods you just kind of
float away with it dan so you just kind
of move involuntarily oh get new
neighbors that's pretty good
let's call Evan yeah man that's a stole
where the wind goes you know dude
imagine is cruising out of town is
knowing your house and you get back in
if they build a new house the worst
thing is when it floats away and you're
not home that's time to be tough to find
yeah oh and also great way to get away
from your spouse though also I know
where you went
yeah so I hit Snowberry let's move it
dude it's that time of year it's
Christmastime
bum bum me and my watch the holidays are
here man they're hair man and nothing
says I love you like time mm-hmm we got
time movement has time dude movement has
the best time yep movement watches
movement has you covered this season
with a beautiful watch collection think
of watches that look nice do think about
your brother opening up a gift and it's
a movement watch oh you're the talk of
the town oh dude small town big town no
town fire hazard whatever bro they'll
chat about it MVM tea movement is making
it easy beautiful curated gift boxes so
this sucker comes wrapped
wrap dude wrapped and you know what else
when I wear mine it stops traffic
really yeah people Gladys happening
where did you get that thing I yell out
movement they started $95 save yourself
save your money that's what you're gonna
do on movement be the big winner this
holiday season with a gift from movement
for you for yourself you can
even put it on an animal yep on your
English Bulldog you look fly man but
also get you one as well so you guys
have matching ones get 15% off today
with free shipping free returns by going
to nvm t-dot-com
slash cats join the movement oh you want
to get your gift to your fan yeah
they're fans they're not here are they
mmm you don't live local they know
better get ready mayor make sure it gets
there on time I'm gonna do I'm doing my
shopping this week and next week I'm
gonna use ship station there's I knew
you're smart man I didn't think you're
gonna say that oh yeah I know about it
dude I know about ship station I don't
you know about ship stays and son I know
a lot about it man I know that here's
the thing about ship station instead of
going to look at all these sites how to
wash ship this do I use a um hummingbird
do I use a carrier pigeon do I use FedEx
business tea what do I use how do I get
it there this is different ship station
does all of that for you in one they're
gonna find the best way to do it and the
best way to do it right now yeah no
matter what you're selling or shipping
Amazon Etsy your own website ship
station brings you all your orders on to
one simple interface it makes it so dang
easy and they work with everybody I'm
including USPS Vanek's UPS everybody you
can compare and choose the best shipping
solution for you and for your customer
quick thing about yourself yeah man no
wonder ship station is the number one
choice of online sellers yep if if
you're tired of all the hassle and all
of the hustle then quit it
take the hustle out of holiday shopping
this season let ship station help you
handle it all with ease yeah wrap
yourself in bubble wrap and see how easy
it is just use the code cats to get 60
days free trial that's too much free of
no hassle stress free holiday shipping
visit shipstation dot-com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
type in K 80s that's right there's great
ways to ship rap your thick sister in a
frickin big hearty French roll and dip
that batch and some mustard if you want
but just make sure to send her on her
way after and use ship station ship
station calm click on the microphone at
the top of the page and type K 80s that
ship station Dyke
in her offer code cats make ship happen
how's your Thanksgiving do great in the
hometown went to Memphis open for a band
bro when I was home the North
Mississippi Allstars til they [ __ ]
with you yeah yeah they're off their big
man I didn't it was like a huge theater
let me do 25 up top I don't really I was
like oh [ __ ] was the crowd there to hear
music or hear your jokes oh they were
there to hear music I had to wrangle
hard but I like been a 1520 it was like
you know what I mean it was in the
pocket but yeah the first 15 I was just
then you did 20 it's 25 yeah but the
band was love they were interesting they
were cool
yeah North Mississippi Allstars dude
they got a song some music all drunk
outdoors the other song with you got
money
[Music]
Oh bro they work were they
now now music just for white people
oh yeah yeah but whether urban too is an
urban crowd no culture corner so they
were happy to see you dude if you're a
black guy that shows up a like a white
man they treat you like oh come on so
now we'll do like a Snoop Dogg remix
during one of our breakdown that's
pretty sometimes Gary over here a
freestyle make it merch anyway out yeah
pretty merchants is dressed the black
guy up in like whatever that's awesome
in your face the end of the day dude
it's so funny cuz I heard about them for
years one of my friends been listening
to enormous if y'all stars and I never
tuned in I don't really listen to music
and then and then one day they said hey
man we love you guys and uh and they
sent me that song I never heard of them
but it's cool hell yeah especially if
they've been playing for long
grammy-nominated I'm sure they sound
real deal I'm just not familiar with the
genre shout out to them they're cool
with you guys yeah gang brah have 2
Mississippi Allstars North Mississippi
North Mississippi do yeah I strike up
the south Mississippi obstinacy what's
up no no white guys that wraps parts
come on now South Mississippi Allstars
is the Ku Klux Klan right right yeah
there's a name for the sound to be
officers yeah KKK right your boy dude
see what he says
it is number yeah right you have saved
on your phone is white buddy
white bad are you sure we know who that
is what you guys do for Thanksgiving
care I stayed here this year instead of
going home I wanted to get sweet potato
pie but after that last episode all I
could think of potato and I couldn't do
it
oh I forgot about that just the cheese
cake yeah do my saddle my mom
it's crazy cuz since then I've been
putting my dick in a grocery bag at
night
it's growing a highs on the side of it
the name hold it with two other the
neighbor kids with toothpicks in it and
put it in a small cup by the window like
what are you trying to do here God look
at Jim Robbie's just disgusted June 8th
June 8th dude it's crazy cuz hey how
long virgin come though with a lawsuit
against us oh the good thing is he won't
have any footage of us making fun of him
yeah deflator yeah or he definitely is
saying the culture corner in court I
know we think it is progressive in year
so now there's gonna be the most racist
thing anybody ever did hey neither one
was forgiven Sarah a lot of brother I've
except that long time I'm trying to get
on Sunday morning love I'm trying to
work for the church okay Saturday night
I'm waiting for Sunday morning brother
you might have to replace me with shame
guilt it's like yeah years ago did you
make a young mix gentleman and a
Vietnamese go sit in the corner of the
room every freedom is the token
think of how to do and then ask the
young asian girl if she gets sick of
Panda Express halfway through did you
guys do that and now I didn't do that
second part yeah yeah my mouth is
watering Florence chicken is it speaking
of that I'm have an orange vanilla coke
right
is risque they don't [ __ ] with that coke
and orange no thanks dude
is it nice mm-hmm there's a new sponsor
swoosh it's good no feels good is it
nice it's just a coat with some orange
when you put it in your head it [ __ ]
feels good dude you're going dude yeah
man feel like you oh it just feels like
anything could happen dude I don't
really have Thanksgiving meal my yeah
would you hit I was born we didn't ask
you
yeah just like nobody talked it was like
well for Thanksgiving are asking there
well for me would you do do you already
unstuff that bird your wife had that
baby yeah I know she was still in the
hospital cementec giblet that's a big
old giblet gizzard um so me my son
shared a pizza
do y'all yeah yeah I mean the three old
[ __ ] of Pizza dude it's sad if you don't
even just think about its way sadder
just thinking about it now I kind of
really good time though man y'all did
yeah we watched Irishmen he loved it and
he also believes Jimmy Hoffa still alive
he watched the Irish man yeah we did
three hours dang he's three years old
and he loved it he loved it he wants to
be Jimmy Hoffa
[Laughter]
so retired UFC fighter and a three year
old watchin the Irishman over a pizza
Thanksgiving dude I'd rather my house
float away bro oh here's some new
neighbors yeah yeah if I live next door
to you I would immediately be putting
pontoons under the edge of my homestead
all aboard
hey how lonely Rhian Thanksgiving that
night we said in mast exile going how's
it it's creepier than somebody who
repeatedly sends out texts on
Thanksgiving Jude yes whoever tech month
eight seven happy thanksgiving [ __ ] you
know I got ya I'm not responding to you
on Thanksgiving yeah grown man thinking
about you Oh
I'm not thinking about you bro with my
family psycho yeah yeah sorry about that
man I gotta take some video at midnight
and went everything okay yeah yeah yeah
I do tennis and then usually I'm asking
myself usually it's a rhetorical be so
hard on yourself
dude I'm sleeping what are you talking
about do you think it's weird if I broke
up my girlfriend say she done with a
ghost
dude Mia my girlfriend went to Shoney's
one time on Christmas bro Joanie's is so
talk
oh no darica that television just cut
out
well weren't old people are tunas like
wow are they doing this from a floating
studio in Vietnam howdy neighbors we're
in a new studio and it's a little little
ratchet it's a little ratchet just how I
like it yeah you're actually your camera
looks like a deposition like you're in
court and you have to are you like
you're met with another like Brendan
Dassey
[ __ ] making a murder you do look like
Brendan Dassey can you bring up a
picture bringing that same name dude hey
nothing's better when he admits to
murdering those people and goes I gotta
get back to class
hey [ __ ] no little dude if he lost some
weight
the boys thick and firmed his hair a
little bit on the sides where that could
be dude if he lost weight and had a face
transplant with Brad Pitt weed looked
very similar he looks like thick
Schwartz and that's how he looks like
he's not getting out either man he's
good my only goal was to get famous
enough to make sure my name was googled
before his that's it dude I think we're
there now I don't know I think he has
her neck and neck Brendan Dassey is a
huge following not anymore
really now not anymore who's supposed to
go to wrestling but he missed it
yeah he's married he goes yeah I killed
him hey am I still gonna make
WrestleMania the detectives like hell no
dummy
dude and the detectives are like say you
did it he's like I did it alright no
problem thanks guys
thought he's gonna get out you think
I'll make Wrestlemania because like [ __ ]
no don't think I like everyone blame the
cops how could you do that I did dumbass
admitted to murder man what are you
talking about part two is boring that's
true first of all here's the thing man
and shout-out to everybody from all
neighborhood if you are underprivileged
and white or black and you didn't kill
somebody do not pretend you killed
somebody
will you go meet with the cops yeah no
matter what yeah get a lawyer yeah or
even if you don't get a lawyer
just don't play Oh what if I did it
you're going to jail yeah don't try to
please the detectives by saying yes oh
man let's get into this episode oh let's
explain why we're a new studio yeah so
people aren't like did they both just
fall off the web we're in a new studio
we moved over to a new studio in Encino
we're trying to produce the podcast
ourselves trying to do everything
ourselves so we were without a studio
Malka hooch out to Lewis and mauka who
they did everything right and this was
our vision this is almost like a digital
TV show right so there's a lot that went
into it and after time we just felt like
we want to Bank on ourselves and just
kind of see if we'd produce it ourselves
yeah it's more creative more ideas and
the studio's gonna look different they
should finish what Thursday Friday get
more cops in this studio to see you know
it's a little sketchier part of town
we're saving money yes and you gotta run
cause cables are definitely some
dangerous cables
there's a hole in that wall whatever
Nick's doing
we got chin behind glass over here so
it's definitely interesting but uh we're
gonna come out we're gonna come out with
some new new logos new logo new
categories new rappers in the new year
we're gonna have new graphics from Burt
Zoomer we're basically better than
ourselves you think we can do it yeah so
enema just makes us work a little harder
I think and just kind of focus on what's
going on if to the kind of in cruise
control because they did and they were
great they did everything yeah we just
show up that's not what we want
they're great we want to make this thing
kind of our our project our baby yeah so
don't touch me dude keep touching me
dang but also don't [ __ ] this up well I
didn't want to tell you dude I took out
a policy on you oh I'm gonna die die but
it's a phrase it is perish oh wow dude
have we got a good deal yeah uh it was
pretty good man yeah it was a lot better
than I thought it was gonna be and
that's because I used policy genius you
know what they're good for if you're a
homeowner you know how tough is to find
the right home insurance piece I'm a
home well I'm a homeowner are you oh
yeah multiple oh do my my uh I have a
cousin that's a homeowner dude and
you're updating online dating other men
dude and interest rates have crept up
over the years man you guys need to
replace your policy all right you can do
it so dang easy and also December is one
of the biggest months so you're like
what am I gonna do oh my god I do
how about policy genius how about that
all right yep my insurance policy at a
place that I had done in Louisiana it
comes up on December 23rd actually so we
got to get a new policy good dude and a
lot of people don't realize their old
policy has been there for decades
those rates aren't as high any more than
you switch it up man the rating has
changed it's a different rate head to
policy genius calm answer a few quick
questions about yourself and your
property then policy genius will compare
your policy against options from top
insurers to make sure you're getting the
best home insurance coverage period yeah
get that rare rate get that unique item
what's what you own a car too right
oh yeah Paul sturgeon scotches well not
least but if you own if you own a home
insurance car
friend enemy anybody get that policy you
want to riche op your current policy
head to policy genius.com you can get
started actually on your smartphone
right now you could do it you'll right
now go to policy genius.com policy
genius when it comes to home insurance
it's nice to get it right do well get it
right get it tight
look man a lot of people bet on those
Browns this weekend dude and they lost
yeah I'm one of them I'm one of them but
I do like to make money I like to watch
sports football NBA UFC college football
dude it's conference championship week
mmm LSU Georgia what's up dog is
beautiful and you go bet on that Joe
borough for Heisman and you wait if
you're doing a parlay you put that as
piece of parlor no matter what yeah yeah
and we know you guys like to bet but
make sure you use my bookie I'm not
talking about my personal bookie named
Dave I'm talk about the company my
bookie dirty Dave yeah he ain't the way
to go hi bug he's the way to go and if
you join right now my book you will
match your deposit half way all the way
up to a thousand bucks that means if you
deposit two thousand you an extra
thousand in your bank account with my
bookie just use the promo code cats
activate the offer once again that's
promo code cats ka TS take advantage of
my bookies generous sign up offer and
that's money in the bank if the if you
throw up some may throw up some that's
even-steven man do you don't think LSU
can beat the breaks off Georgia I think
they might beat the balls off that
bulldogged about to neuter those animals
what's up just use promo code ka TS to
activate the offer you got to activate
it activate dude visit my bookie dot AG
today you play you win you pay oh I
decide man first this is Kade mata it's
our boy decayed
I got a who's more likely my name is
Kade motto from Cohoes New York that's
the upstate New York that neck tag
country Angela who's more likely to win
in a rap battle spit a hotter 16 I got
Theo cuz he's from Louisiana he's from
the dirty he's
I saw at the top with filthy Brennan you
read at a third-grade level I can't give
it to you hurts hard it was more likely
Gang Gang buzz-buzz hey you definitely
look like your nicest uh well he looks
like he's in nicest that guy seem like a
nice guy
yeah third grades [ __ ] hard bro seems
like joke ha ha Dijon go give me a
[ __ ] hero
um I'll wrap that lets you all date it's
a guy road dude first year oh no it's a
year of cycling dude there's the GA
sound if you have time to say it bro
watch it's JIRA dude now let's you all
day you rap just automatically and your
your speech I don't know man I don't
think I can get at her actual rap battle
like a like a [ __ ] 8 mile goes public
hey I don't want to do that here's how I
can't stand white rappers be you rap
everything no ha
here's like hey how's your berry like
good beers good Bubba Sparxxx take it
easy man [ __ ] sleazy take it easy breh
is here the truth is neither one of us
want to actually have to do a rap right
now no way but you've done a rapid
that's so you did too
no no I didn't rap in it I danced in it
you actually had lyrics and we remember
you went buzz buzz in it too
yes Jem you have a rap video you're a
rapper dude no rapper yeah I did one bad
Oh actually name bet we did a good video
man yeah Malibu's Most Wanted style of
its time yes [ __ ] was dope
it was of its oh yeah so definitely this
one's easy deal I don't know you
basically a rapper on stage no I don't
think so you rapped I'm doing stand-up
no you rapped it dropping bars won't
even have a band I don't have a band you
don't need to you just a rapper you're
like mmm nah I'm not Brendan yeah you
text me whatever you want a stage when
I'm more like real you went I'm so
nervous
mom spaghetti oh you're thinking about
Chris D'Elia rearranging stuff in his
garage
dude that's who's more likely to win in
a rap battle maybe we should have one
huh I'm not doing a rap battle um white
dude I'm not doing it well you would win
you got to connect with your inner self
bruh well then herself doesn't wanna
wrap yourself man ask yourself right now
do I want to rap everybody would sack
nope is there anything more awkward than
white guys rapping I think it's it's
poetry it's called more poetry slam
poetry came out to give white guys a
chance more and then comment said hold
my [ __ ] weed and then when I'm as a
slam poet the best yeah
the best yeah I don't know man I get is
there any good white rappers coming up
there's that guy young gravy have you
seen him really
your white rappers let's pull some of
his beats jeez he's probably most famous
right do jeez he shot out Loyola
University New Orleans probably went to
the same school was he from the bay yeah
but he went to school loyal University
there's young crazy oh dude you don't
even forget it little Dickie best white
far as young gravy bro damn the girls
hoarding year drums [ __ ] that's young
gravy red thought blue thought oh yeah
could you beat young gravy absolutely
not that's his job here's what I say for
next episode we got to come up with a
rap I'm not rapping what about a series
of words that rhyme we agree with that
maybe maybe dude our own rap maybe we
could do a rap together what about a
light what about a king in this thing
rap well what about this let's ask
people okay we'll do them y'all also
send some in if you don't mind some
fancy machine absolutely yeah and also
yeah we'll see how many black fans we
have which is Derrick Derrick submits
one rap battle
I guess Ivana disguised so there we go
there we go we'll try and come up with
one and then a hot man I can already
tell her bad about it ours is gonna be
not gonna be 85 percent one with the Rat
King gang bra and shut up to the new Rat
King t-shirt I got to do my mom one she
goes I want something to wear to Burger
King that's what she said the other day
I don't do it I said I got you mom that
whopper with cheese mama yeah she gets
that junior whopper usually yeah with
cheese it's a treat on Sunday uh I don't
know my mama doesn't eat Jude for my
money there's not a better burger than a
whopper with cheese and ketchup only
that's living that's living like it
whopper yeah you don't like whoppers no
man oh oh like eating cardboard you like
the impossible burger huh huh from Jack
Jake's down under what's that play sky
don't know what no duck urge a Burger
King is the impossible but now I need
all say it's a bunch of phonies on there
eating it to see the commercial also
view a real vegan you ain't going to
Burger King dumbass yeah you're not
giving them money cuz they slaughter two
animals yeah that's true huh freaking
idiots that's a good point but dude I
think if the world started in an bro
people are gonna be eating each other
people gonna be an animal vegans gonna
be vegan as a delicacy I feel like do
you have any vegans of Vietnam cat is
that a popular thing or is everybody yes
vegans I don't think so
a lot of pescetarians where you're at
yeah yeah a lot of pescetarians - is
there any fish guessing by Brendan okay
I'm gonna call I used to be a
pescetarian did you make it only have
fish can have red meat or chicken
anything just fish and vegetables damn
nose fun that's scary
that's scary yeah okay oh shut up -
pescetarians what else we got we got a
little Bay Club boys up first this is
Austin from Austin Texas let's hear it
oh wow cute kid man buzz buzz that's
oohs your favorite wrestler Austin is it
Stone Cold Steve Austin or the rock
buzz-buzz is three months two years
three years a while dude is advanced
rock was this question some kids are so
dumb at three yeah very alarmed to be
around those kids and act like they're
normal
oh yeah like all your sons great he's
like yeah your son's basically a puppy
yeah your son's is over there just
hiding fingers in his butt dude kids do
that dude kids love their butts once
they find out about him yeah my little
nephew us almost week he just kept
talking about his bud
he'll be fine I gotta leave them in here
they're like playing games jumping on
the bed at one point they took their one
of them took their shorts also the other
one takes them off you know right catch
a case yeah let's do our 19 and you
gotta be cool you can't be like all you
guys are naked you want to make them
feel bad you know just go have fun guys
uncle Thea will be downstairs yeah
uncle Theo would be at a restaurant nah
I walked it outside my hands up after
that I felt nervous I told my brother
you with the newspaper to make sure I
told my brother straightaway they both
took their pants off and I left the room
not it bro you know I remember I was in
school when I was at LSU and um the
professor he said he was statistics or
something he said statistically one out
of like there was six hundred students
in the class and he's like one four of
you guys will be convicted of some sort
of sex offense is this New Orleans is
Louisiana no LSU shout out go Tigers
buffer oh he's praying for and LSU you
mean 50% of you will be accused of
sexual assault hit one and two of you
[ __ ] well then he goes and one
of you guys will have will be a
convicted statistically one of you guys
to be a convicted pedophile and I stood
up and you helped not it died laughing
a couple of kids I think we're like I
don't know they didn't even the head
like no feeling about it on my kid who
kicked the chair they're all okay all
right dude well yeah you'll figure it
out buddy what does this guy want to
know if his son's gonna grow older you
guys like the rocker Stone Cold War I'm
gonna go stone cold cuz to me he still
feels like a wrestler for me to rock his
transgressed in a more of like a marble
just anybody can roll that cat through
the woods now yeah and hey Rock quit
taking every movie role we don't need to
see him every [ __ ] yes Annie he was in
black Annie dude any traits all the
movies it's ridiculous man yeah it's not
a crazy Rock is mrs. Doubtfire how dare
you yeah mrs. Rock fire I'm not trying
to see that [ __ ] I'm stone-cold all
goddamn day he's a real and I know stone
cold he's a great dude do you yeah real
good dude
hmm and he drinks beer and he just lives
in frickin Marina del Rey he's a good
dude man wow yeah I'm a stone-cold fan
yeah I'm gonna go stone cold too man I
like any man they can wear a vest and
also have his chest out like that and I
also like a guy who doesn't freakin post
on Instagram every time he works out all
right dude all right
does that rock the rock every time do ya
relax
I work out too if I'm the rock dude I'm
the shale you know so it's a pebble yeah
I don't know what I am dude I'm the
slate once you gain the same supplements
as the rock and then talk to us you know
I'm saying boys juju juju see I need to
get on something you think he's on juice
you think the Rocky's huge what do you
guys think about him Kat all the women
think about the rock yeah I think the
rock was more attractive when he first
got into the WWF I don't really find him
attractive now but I will say Stone Cold
Steve Austin was the first white man I
ever found attractive oh really yeah
usually I like white boys I'm just a
little more cautious of them oh yeah
that makes sense a little more cautious
but I like white men I get what are you
gonna get
is there a general consensus that that
Asian women don't trust white man you
think no Asian women love white men mmm
go away sometimes you want I didn't hear
you fully Asian women love white men
interesting that's news to me
do you you say all the time that you
don't think Asian women look at you yeah
I think if you grew up in a
predominantly Asian area they'd swoop
you up like a WoW some sort of trap do
you bite now I'm not like her vine or
something yes Irvine was San Francisco
shaking his head any other San Jose we
need to get chin hits huh it's Chan
married yet I'll answer that no we're
working on it we're trying I see I want
to do this segment gender we set up
dates for the chin on tinder we should
do that easily yeah and if you know a
decent lady for Chim why don't you
submit that huh
we'll do a gender segment let's submit
some ladies for Chan if you have a
sister or somebody you care about that's
a loving woman but in kind of in the LA
area we don't do a long-distance we'll
fly a lady in we need someone who's kind
of local for them because it's tough
enough as it is
okay so if you're in the cow would say
California yeah we'll say San Antonio or
West and we'll go Fresno or lower yeah
see I would go I would go Pasadena or
lower and then Irvine or higher we kind
of the LA area because that's where he
lives didn't get him a train though dude
a lot of beautiful ladies will get on a
train and if there's any ethnicity
that's just absolutely out chin that
well I'm gonna say in ethnicity and you
shake your head if you're not into it
okay ready I'll go you go I'm not in
this why not huh dude I'm still trying
to work force a large racist enough bro
I'm trying to stay out of this kind of
stuff why because I can't win white girl
urine oh can the easy when the layup huh
we're sorry black girl
Wow so okay what did you have three
hands he went like this this foreign
girl
okay so does everybody so basic like
Mexican girl oh wow
he likes Latin lilac motion what about
Brazilian Colombian thumbs up double
thumb do they have to speak English just
barely okay a little bit just to
understand listen to it it kind of
sounds like my hooker won't my nanny
really what's her name is Morell de Oh
beautiful name
we call her Izzy ooh ah can they have
kids chin
we got oh absolutely not chin doesn't
like kids but if the kids are feet and
male that's okay right is it what it was
a stripper you'd be cool with a stripper
a working girl no chance well depending
you can kind of put up with some of it
we're just trying to set some filters
here for him so people know what to
submit people know what to submit they
know he's a decent man what if they're
really short
do you like short how little piggy back
ride guy huh okay that sounds great then
we'll do Chinna we'll do a gender
segment let's submit some women for Chen
fan submit chicks for for Chen yeah and
let's see what let's see what a goat and
Kings thing pay for the date we'll set
you up on the date nice huh yeah Derek's
looking fired up he's like I got to take
my girl out anyway you think it's a
Korean barbecue oh dude that's what
we'll do
we'll do a double date with Derek and
his girl and chin in this new Korean
barbecue okay
cool but don't film it with your [ __ ]
GoPro the whole time and freak her out
in an edit together I get a great night
yeah I don't do that yeah don't do that
Chan you know yeah let's look maybe the
third fourth date would document it yeah
tighten up Chandu don't see here all
right let's move on we got Chan today
we got a plan yeah you got a plan for
change
yeah what else we got fifty-two percent
the rock okay all right because using
Jumanji but still a surprise come on for
stone cold he hadn't wrestled him wince
in probably a decade he's a classic 316
that was my I grabbed the beer three six
nine whatever those guys they get they
died no that's not three 6 mafia how
dare you cat but great guess I would
have guessed that to window to the wall
same guys Union jinx yeah that's who
they are
oh they sing the song of the saints use
that stand up and get crunk danger song
tonight you yeah no yeah oh yeah what
happened yeah got shot or something
didn't he I think yang I think yang went
through transition and yang got shot one
of them is on HGH a young I think yang
young now one of them yeah definitely
saliva they might be on tour with the
new kids on the block international yeah
yeah they also I think one of them smoke
somebody's joins you cuz they had that
whisper song didn't whether you see my
balls
oh and now if that isn't a [ __ ]
rapist anthem how that became a hit you
got a question America what some say
it's just a beat him don't wait you see
it's hard to fully accuse louis c.k when
there's also hit songs out there wait'll
you see my dick whispering t to your
radio dude they're giving you guys signs
you wonder where they're at not doing
good is what they're doing great I don't
think so dude I bet they're performing
at a freaking bat mitzvah in Beverly
Hills man and just doing wait you see my
dick oh yeah here's my shut up it's
party
wouldn't dude dude what were some of
their hits what were their biggest hits
yeah the wall the salt oh oh they're
performing Friday December 13th in San
Antonio theater Road yes Aikido I
performed there which is where the
border is actually where we'll accept
gender dates from ironically well we'll
see yeah they had some hits saltshaker
wait I don't know wait say aye aye yah
Oh whistle whistle hey these boys these
boys just create music dafuq that's all
they were and then once they did all
that they're like we're all out of ideas
they also have a song called first booty
on duty booty on duty then the next
songs all by myself then other songs
called pull my hair
yeah the twerk you later put that thing
down the nerve calmer oh definitely he's
just nicknames for their Weiner I think
I am graves hey how about this one
whether bass it's called take your
clothes off boys are disgusting
that's what I'm saying they should start
dude if you had a podcast I'll be done
let me go relationship advice boys oh
man let's help some people oh oh
heavily ever we gotten any response on
social media cat that anybody's had
actually been help hey have you ever
followed up with anybody and
relationship advice be right do my
life's in shambles I listen to Brendon I
hooked up with that stripper we have
twins man I'm 19 Gang Gang buzz buzz
vocalist thanks guys yeah
do we need an inmate to send in a gang
gang but yeah we do man bunch of inmates
the only response from social media is
that somebody asked to have their
segment taken down from relationship
advice
oh that's cuz I had like that woman
handcuffed in the back is on hey man
here with my wife what do you think
first date I think you know the first
date and she was in the back yeah and
then remember he like a week later Zach
a man my parents saw that [ __ ] mom you
said we didn't ask for it you send it to
us yeah my friend audacity audacity now
what was it pregnancy it's a whole
different I loved Vernon dad city though
Brendon damned a city dude he gets out
he's not you know when FBD do free burn
and a city you got the king in this
thing we support brennan audacity we
started GoFundMe yeah all right what do
you guys it's crazy because some people
would almost say that some one of the
best things that ever could have
happened to him was getting into an
environment where he could learn eat go
to the gym young people yeah talking out
of his mom's house get out of it
barbecuing with his goddamn uncle who's
clearly a murderer all the goddamn time
how about that dude if it all goes on a
murderer I will say this he frequents
murders okay yeah it's a little too
fishy for me the other thing is part two
was him pretending he was a lawyer
trying to prove his innocence I'm not
trying to see that [ __ ] either he's
angry yeah it's him pretending he's a
lawyer put glasses on doesn't make you a
lawyer bro he sounds like a montage of
the Steven Avery sounds like somebody
would play for the Atlanta Braves
doesn't it all right here we go guys no
it's more Evan from Arkansas tight beard
yeah what up Bo and Brandon I got some
relationship advice for you boys
basically
you know I've I've been getting in with
this girl she's a little bit older than
me I'm a I'm a young cat I'm about 21
and you know she's a few years older
than me thinks she's four years older
than me but anyway you know the issue is
and where I need advice is this girl
said female has a few kiddos on deck
okay you know I'm talking three kiddos
different ages and a couple different
daddies if you know what I'm saying
oh yeah and you know God's I'm Judith
our Juice I'm not trying to have three
kids yeah I'm I trust you Father three
guys make messages stop pursuing it give
up on her before you know I become baby
daddy number four
I think order you know you think I gotta
stick it out and become alright I can't
dude here's the thing if she has three
kids bro she ain't stopping that womb
ain't stopping that's her thing
yeah that's that she got you know she
really has that things like a damn that
over he's like a pitching machine bro
you know that thing's gonna keep
throwing zygotes down the spout daddy
I mean I think you could try to get the
coolest baby out of her you know if you
want to make it like a competition with
other local men in the area I mean I
think this alley cat version Wolverine
should be happy that he found a girl the
[ __ ] handsome guy where's he from yeah
bro Arkansas lot of beautiful and not a
lot of single women in Arkansas they
lock them down there they lock them yeah
shout out to the Razorbacks dude
shoutout to Norman Robinson remember him
I can't from motel 6 or what's that tape
not that no I'm thinking of two
different people thinking of the coach
for the Arkansas Razorback I'm trying to
think of yeah I'm trying to get along
Richardson I don't know
we don't you can you google norm
Richardson for me who's the most famous
gotta come out of Arkansas go climax
no I'm thought yeah for sure Billy
Clinton your boy right there Norwich
it's bad oh that's right no that ain't
no maybe I bought that urban gentleman
to the right in the red shirt who is
that Noland written that's him is acting
oh he's the basketball coach hey alright
dude would you give the inmate the pitch
late a little late he does he's either
in it on the new set of sting the King
God who's the most famous professional
player to play for come out of Arkansas
there was that dope basketball player
back in the day it cut Reeves country
big country Ruiz is he's from Arkansas
he was out of Kansas I think do
shut it Steve Atwater no I'm go to uh
Mahan
he looks Jones right there oh that's
right he's a baller
uh dick Burt did you do basketball
famous dick famous dick bumpass time I
dig buck yes mm-hmm Billy Ray Smith
Cornelius
what's up know Cornelius Williamson who
I was thinking of Courtney's Winston
that was it yeah he played under Nolan
Richardson otherwise you got Bill
Clinton Billy Clinton it's so crazy
thinking him at Arkansas isn't it BC
dude I like Bill Clinton I like Bill
Clinton - yeah it's cool do you think
that Bill Clinton's when was the last
time he booked Bill Clinton at sex with
his wife though Paul honestly they say
about in separate houses yeah they said
you know he's pregnant president they
would be you know he'd had his own side
house for his hoes Wow
I believe that if you're president do
you should get a couple O's I think what
are they doing Vietnam cat do you know
do you know what kind of wood
they have in Vietnam what's the Vietnam
structure will you look it up there the
president of Vietnam is kind of tough
yeah actually I kind of I don't I know
you're not being I know you're American
yeah you know I've learned that this
season of the show but well I appreciate
you remembering that yeah
young pootron Who am I thinking in how
do you say that ng you want you I mean
do you want the English pronunciation or
the venom ease pronunciation cuz in
English a lot of people say win or new
win but in venom ease it's we know is
what we wow it's beautiful I was gonna
skip the Lyon pootron and he's the
champion over there right now or he's
the president hey the guy in the
Philippines is the main one right yeah
like kills everybody yeah really
yes he let he basically told everyone if
there is a known drug user or drug
seller you can go ahead and shoot them
in the streets yeah that was like his
whole thing to clean up the streets of
drug use did it help uh a lot of people
were like just killing random people
saying hey drug user drug seller right
and just getting away with if you're a
gay to there kill you yeah people my
wife's a drug use that'd be easy
I saw snortin coats on shot or anything
almost easier than getting rid of your
wife on a cruise yeah that's American
stuff that old cruise life it's getting
expensive that packing ah I'm gonna go
on the Caribbean it expands the
two-for-one yeah and what were they
asking about if she has three kids I
don't know what do you guys think don't
what are you doing
how old was he he was 21 not for you
yeah you can't even speak yet yeah if
you're not ready for a family and you
yeah you have to talk fast or two we
have kids yeah yeah that senses that
longer to get out don't be around kids
bro be an uber driver yeah you could do
over ma'am and over you get to meet
people and you can kill somebody if you
want over you can get get a woman there
people are kidnapping women all the time
do a nuber now yeah all the time and
women are really it's a tough it's
tough gig imagine leaving the house
every day I'm scared straight let alone
for cash yeah even though I'm scared to
get out can we cue another cop sound
right there was a window right yeah
that's what's crazy oh really yeah yeah
filled in but that's crazy brother right
out there what else you got Dee
King at her sting it will finish it over
there alright let's do it I was well but
itza from South Johannesburg South
Africa
what's up Brandon and Theo and Moritz
are coming to you from Johannesburg
South Africa big fan of you both and one
of my guy friends recently got engaged
but his girlfriend proposed to him he
said yes seems fine with it so I got a
king it'll sting it for you bills
proposing to guys thanks a gang gang
buzz-buzz cheers love oh that's
Australia money where's she from
oh man South Africa is the wild wild no
that's Africa bro she's in Africa she's
not Africa she doesn't forget the end of
it but it's South Africa dangerous all
of Africa dangerous there is awesome
friction there I will say that major
friction that's true you got to deal
with animals humans everything in Africa
it there's a lot of cheetah take your
kid oh yeah did even one of those strong
Willoughby's or whatever those things
are dude them black water buffalo Oh
Harvey bro selling drugs come across a
[ __ ] hippo oh that's what they deal
with we got gang violence out here they
deal with hippos and [ __ ] cheetahs
yeah we're complaining about mosquitos
yeah we're complaining about a little
fire on the freeway and these people are
[ __ ] you worry about the West Nile
that's the top virus do you know wonder
what she's saying girls proposing guys
yeah cuz i dying
so like let's just do it man
he's oh well I guess I like it I'm an
indecisive male you know I come from a
long line of indecisive males and uh I'm
surprising them even here you know
because somebody had to make a decision
or a couple decisions had to be made and
so I think if a woman asks I like it
because then you can say yes or no I'm a
little old fashioned you know a little
old fashioned expect it depends all the
girl does if it's like kind of sweet and
just kind of you know you know it was
the right timing I guess I'm into it but
she does CrossFit she's like real Balkan
[ __ ]
she has calloused hands and she gets
down on her knee yeah dude what are we
doing yeah yeah I don't want that
oh no if she's like dust off chops I
talk to you for a second yeah oh yeah
power
yeah actually jumps out of a Chevy and
gets down on a knee actually man the
more you bring it up like that like when
it gets to the actual physical act of it
it's gonna be really embarrassing she
was a full rack of ribs you got a salad
of salmon on it she's down on a knee
whole dudes like what the [ __ ] is
happening yeah she carries you out sure
man you turned me out on this and
brother okay dunno you needed to talk to
your friend okay I know that there's
some exceptions
yeah there's exception if you're in a
coma or something like that and you're
late and she found the ring you were
gonna ask her and you're gonna die yeah
that makes sense
and that's beautiful man but yeah she
gets out of it you know truck leaves the
truck running gets a kiss yes just to go
back to work he's in part and takes a
construction hat alive sits down on me
and then just Nick arm for nobody
[Music]
dude that's a man you're talking about
it's a male but there's also if you have
an eloquent woman that like ballets over
to you and does a pirouette and surprise
you yeah they can do it cute but yeah I
don't know man [ __ ] I quit CrossFit
because it's girls beat my ass they're
just not into it man
it's not for me yeah it's not for me
there I think it would be too much I
think what do you guys think yeah what
the [ __ ] am I talking about dude no way
okay miss no way you let Oprah do it if
you're a billionaire you can do that's
the best that's the price dude if you
want to feel how Americans feel about it
do it at a baseball game see if you get
booed out you feel like hey yeah you
feel like Trump at a [ __ ] le doctors
can you get booed at that [ __ ] Stadium
dude dude if you're a billionaire though
the rules get different who was and
results the other day he was talking
about whenever the president said
billionaires and grab women by the [ __ ]
and how a Sony who were complaining and
he's like but billionaires ain't asking
you know no that's what they do
yeah have you ever had a billion or grab
your [ __ ] that's just yeah yeah yeah
thousand airs grabbing your puss out
really good feeling like cat you would
propose to your man yeah cat you really
pretty strong mind absolutely no you'd
have a snake tattoo on your forearm and
then pretend you're not gonna propose to
you but yeah but are you gonna email him
a bunch in the middle of the night and
say proposed proposed subject proposed
also and then right in propose no I
wouldn't email him but if I really
wanted a guy to propose I would slowly
Incept into into one of my friends to
tell him to do it you know just like
slowly pressure over time but I'm not
proposing to any goddamn man no no wait
for him to do it yeah if you don't do it
like no you're gonna lose your chance
I'm gonna find someone else to propose
to me wow that and if I'm walking down
the aisle and you don't cry I'm walking
the bath I'm walking back I'm not gonna
run away bride situation yeah Oh
here's under your eyes when I walk out
down the hall you might be crying
because he's you know it's over but
still you got to pretend it's not and
still pretend yeah yeah yeah yeah right
I'm just happy to be here or you're
crying cause your life is over and they
have a little stick you can get you put
the stuff in your EIN and we'll make you
cry yeah Tom Cruise does it wow so
that's surprising yet cuz you won't do
you won't let him propose but you want
him a crime you come down the aisle
I won't propose to him if you won't
propose to him right but you want him to
cry be emotional
my boyfriend we're not too emotional
yeah hear me out here stereotype agents
aren't that emotional ah I I don't think
we show emotion very often but we are
emotional I think we just keep it in a
lot of you cry behind closed doors they
cry in heaven a lot of them that's fair
they finally get up and just let it go
probably feels good oh how about so good
dude they are the masters of suspense
but you say exercise disguise oh yeah
maybe this guy's I guess I don't know I
don't have any good enough
trick-or-treaters and I don't have
agents in my neighborhood I have no idea
I mean either what else we got fans vote
on it no I was just a camera saying it
okay I'm gonna say sing it do not yeah
I'm gonna go unless he's dying of cancer
and can't talk yeah or if he was in a
fire or something but if he wasn't in a
fire nothing everything's okay and
normal I'm gonna say no yeah the last
one this is Tyler Evans okay walking
alone make sure we do newzealand at
night there and I got cocaine
it is Gang Gang but who what do you say
from the beginning
he's from New Zealand and walking alone
at night walking alone at night good way
to meet women good way dude good way to
meet death
good way to get rate dude oh you be
honest while walking on tonight my heads
on a swivel
yeah heads on a swivel dude yeah walking
alone at night it's very old-fashioned I
feel like yeah yeah it's kind of
something that you don't do anymore
because people always get killed doing
it we're great yeah it's like it's
almost like you know the consequences
yeah even the guys could commit the
crimes like you're the one that's
walking I'm gonna do it but I just see
no one's out in forever
just happy yeah why are you you asked
for this I didn't want to do this you
knew when you came out walking down the
shore on your own yeah you have to
goddamn life it's so dangerous but I
guess it because here's the thing most
people do it the only people still doing
it or criminals or people that are
peeping tom errs we're looking for drugs
yeah yeah I also you walk in that night
yeah Brian [ __ ] walking for nothing
bro what are you doing out there do you
get the buddy system looking for trouble
dude hold your buddy's hand you're
looking to get murdered you're looking
to get lit up by a couple of men dude
here's the other thing I think about you
do the buddy system say mean you're
walking down the street holding hands
there's me a hate crime yeah you can't
even do the buddy system anymore do you
think it gay rude and you keep growing
your hair out
I keep growing my hair now I think it's
too [ __ ] walking down Hollywood
Boulevard we getting beat up dude no do
you think about that make sure you keep
that hat on what what just happened
basically you can't walk down the street
especially you and me if we keep growing
our hero I think if you gotta have a
sword or something with you you have to
be prepared these days if you're gonna
walk in at night cuz everybody else are
prepared
nobody's milling around at night going
for a stroll if they are it's a setup
dude yeah to set up they're looking for
drugs they have drugs nobody's like oh
yeah my dog ran off or something there's
none of that [ __ ] going on any nothing
good has come from walking at night
alone yeah
never yeah so Richard Simmons try to
pick me up one time they do in Hollywood
yeah it's awesome man we're right
outside the comedy store yeah pulled up
I was like oh you big boy out like who
the hell
that is him in a white Land Rover oh we
had a great night
your big who's that big biscuit okay
some energy ha ha so I'm gonna say I
like it it feels adventurous when you do
it it feels like you could do something
crazy or something crazy could happen
feels like you could do anything if you
walk it alone by a night and finally get
to your destination I love walking past
somebody's house seeing like a family in
their window or something to see them
living and they don't even know that you
[ __ ] exist just be who you want to be
a piece of their mail or some [ __ ] do
you do whatever you want dude take a
piece of their [ __ ] window sill okay
still want their avocados were you up in
Salinas - this family has avocados
outside night your gangster King it
broke get out I king it cuz it's living
it's also you're gonna be a badass if
you don't see the world man walk at
night that's it that's it
well hope not too many people walk in
night well they make their own choices
man dude new studio new studio coming
along cult recording we're gonna get
those cables off edie by next week we're
gonna have some more come along beer
with us fans yeah beer with us there
with the sin and some wraps to sin and
maybe a we're you know we're gonna be
doing the Refresh of like some things in
the new year
theme music we maybe get some more theme
music you know just a whole new if
you're musically gifted sent some [ __ ]
in for us man
yeah put some stuff in man send in maybe
some videos of just gang gang buzz-buzz
we could put some of those in the intro
uh-huh people saying gang getting
buzz-buzz yeah an outro or do something
we're gonna we're gonna make segments
yeah you're gonna come up with some new
segments one of them too we want to tell
right now is the name game so um what do
we do
how many guys like something both you
both can name who can name more like me
right you guys like concepts like cars
animals Pasha's hats
yeah oh I got this new LA Kings head -
dude I went to my first Kings game how
was it [ __ ] dope in person right bro
it was great it sucks in person it's
fantastic yeah I wish they would put
another puck out there sometimes though
and give everybody more people a chance
because some of the guys will action
right yeah yeah I'm with it for one
minute at the end of each period they
threw another puck out yet to really be
on your appeasing but you know when
you're a polar bear out there mix it up
yeah let's get out there did he toss
that guy out there who was look he's got
three kids on the way yeah yeah you know
in the dark make it all difficult yeah
but uh shout out LA Kings and they won
they say guy stopped it at the very end
Campbell that was his name the goalie he
stopped it at the last I like hockey in
person just on TV
yeah it's opposite of porno yeah yeah
man I'm not doing any of that you're on
the road dude what are you doing yeah
what's going on yep I'll be at The
Wiltern in Los Angeles on December 10th
I'm going to La Jolla for one night
actually this week but it's already sold
out just hit the comedy store one night
they're coming down there yeah it's
gonna blows down I'm trying to practice
this set for next week
and I got this new Theo von merch store
Theo von merch store that's a dope shirt
Theo von store.com your big fake friend
excel in that bro did you need a model
you know plus-size model bro and then
all the King in this thing merch is
gonna be on sale - yes sir so that'll be
on sale by the end of the week and we're
relaunching some new merch coming up
it's really good time man I mean can see
this week Friday Saturday next week I'm
in New Jersey bar got a one night
Saturday night I got a casino that's
gonna be beautiful man yeah I'm coming
to Toronto those dates are on sale - now
I'm not sure where it's at but another
on sale sounds great yeah I'm excited
man gang man touch me oh we're bro we've
got this let's do it thank you guys for
the support